welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this section we want to talk about
the deuteron which is one of the two
stable isotopes of hydrogen
the atom is called deuterium
the nucleus actually contains one proton
and one neutron so it's quite simple and
so we can use this as an example to
understand the concept of binding energy
and how we can create
objects of heavier mass or nuclear
heavier mass
we can do this by bringing protons and
neutrons together
and when we do that they
have a likelihood of binding together to
deuteron
and they release an energy in form of a
photon of 2.3 mev
so um the way to understand is that the
combination the bound combination of the
protons and neutron have a favor more
favorable energy state which is visible
in this nuclear potential here so the
deuteron
lives as a combination of the proton and
the neutron here
in order to now split up the deuteron
which is stable we have to add energy we
have to add at least 2.3 mev of energy
in order to release the proton and and
the neutron and make them free
the natural abundance of
deuterium in the earth is rather limited
um with
0.0115 percent in the earth but
nevertheless deuterium is extremely
useful and extremely important in the
evolution of the universe
in the
synthesis of more heavier elements
as it's kind of a part of the chain
which allows the creation of helium and
then helium can be used in order to
create even heavier
nuclei
to give you in a sense and the numbers
um
the mass of the deuteron is
2.01355
[Music]
in
atomic units
and the mass of the pronoun proton is
about one the mass of the neutron is a
little bit bigger but also about one so
in order to now get the binding energy
so the energy which is kind of stored in
the deuteron when it's binding together
the proton and the neutron uh can be
[Music]
accessed by
adding the proton and the neutron mass
and subtracting the mass of the deuteron
again that's the minimal energy needed
in order to free up the proton and the
neutron
more in it if you
add more energy then you actually also
give kinetic energy to the proton and
the neutron in this reaction
um the deuteron was discovered in
[Music]
1934 and it's fundamental also in
production of hydrogen bombs which were
produced about 20 years later
so the deuteron itself is is a rather
important nuclei again as i said before
it's it's fundamental its stability is
fundamentally important in nuclear
synthesis after the big bang